[Musique]
face à la première
monde
bienvenue dans notre émission politique
face à la première sur les supports
numériques et l'antenne radio de
martinique la première je vous remercie
pour votre constance à notre écoute
madame monsieur je souhaite la bienvenue
à nos invités dans notre nouvelle
implantation de la tour ou luminaires
situe à la pointe simon à fort de france
plus précisément au 1 de la rue loulou
boislaville le nom à retenir à
l'émission organisée et réalisé
aujourd'hui par un cedrick banks et le
grand débat national lancé mardi 15
janvier par le président de la
république emmanuel macron pour tenter
de trouver une issue à la crise dite
rapidement des gilets jaunes aura-t-il
lieu en martinique faut-il y prendre
part ou pas ce genre de consultation
ouverte à tous sur la base du
volontariat n'est-elle pas faussé
d'avancé autant de questions que je
propose à mes invités d'aborder entre
autres sujets puisque nous parlons
également des perspectives économiques
sociales et politiques pour la
martinique en 2019
c'est ainsi que j'ai le plaisir de
recevoir aujourd'hui quatre militantes
et militants engagés dans la vie
publique avec par ordre alphabétique
béatrice bel et bon jour à la maison oui
dont chaudron chose à tous les éditeurs
vous êtes la première secrétaire
fédérale du parti socialiste préfère et
vous exercer le métier de cadre de
collectivités tout à fait gabriel jean
marie qui à mes côtés qui est le
secrétaire générale de la cgtm bonjour
monsieur jean-marie on soit en vous êtes
enseignant de formation d'un profession
à côté de nous se trouve pierre marie
joseph bonjour monsieur marie-josèphe un
soin qui est chef d'entreprise bien
connu président d'honneur de
l'association pour la promotion de
l'industrie api et pdg du groupe portant
son nom gpm j ai enfin marine est
trempée montgeron adam tan pays
bonjour bonjour à tous et à toutes
membre du comité du conseil exécutif de
la collectivité territoriale de
martinique est chargé d affaires d
développe du développement économique
chargé du développement économique voilà
j'y viens et vous êtes également chef
d'entreprise dans le civil si je puis
dire merci en tout cas à toutes et à
tous devant participer à notre mission
allons déjà une question
vous êtes posé madame mesdames et
messieurs où sont passés les gilets
jaunes en martinique
béatrice baylet ils sont ils sont
présents ils sont en petit nombre mais
je pense que comme on a pu le remarquer
encore il y a probablement beaucoup de
gilet jaune
ils sont je crois tous les samedis matin
sur la savane et organise régulièrement
des réunions et je le sais pour avoir
été invité en tout cas enfin invité non
va pas dire ça mais en tout cas avoir
été acceptée lors de leurs échanges de
certains échanges mais vous dites qu'ils
sont discrets un peu nombreux ça vous
étonne
ou au contraire vous trouvez ça
totalement logique les grandes
manifestations que nous avons eu par
exemple à la réunion est le seul les
pays d'outre-mer à avoir eu une
mobilisation de ces fameux gilet jaune
durant un mois ou encore dans plusieurs
villes petites moyennes et grandes de la
france continentale est bien ici en
martinique c'est étonnant si on prononce
aucun cas il n'y pas une plus grande
ampleur de ce mouvement c'est parce que
ça oui c'est surprenant c'est surprenant
parce que je pense qu'on vit une
situation tout de même sociales
notamment assez assez préoccupante en
martinique surprenant également parce
que nous avons quand même l'habitude de
savoir manifester notre mécontentement
quant à l'organisation
et d'ailleurs on nous prête souvent le
surnom de l'îlot grève mais je crois que
ça révèle aussi que définitivement le la
contestation tout cas citoyenne passe
chez nous je sais le constat que j'en
fais passe chez nous par les
organisations syndicales
probablement parce que les effets de
groupe ils sont déjà plus cohérent son
son
construit autour d'une action syndicale
et autour de convictions qui sont celles
des militants syndicaux mais je pense
néanmoins que d'ailleurs j'ai reçu un
petit tract des gilet jaune que j'ai là
d'ailleurs qu'il ya un travail qui se
fait de réflexion sur la situation en
martinique gamme qu'elle jean marie qui
est secrétaire général de la cgt m vous
êtes tout de suite très tôt démarquer du
mouvement des gilets jaunes qui
appelaient à manifester ici puisque dès
la première manifestation publique vous
avez tenu a en quelque sorte mettre les
choses au clair en vous demandant de ce
mouvement spontané et en réaffirmant
tout de même la légitimité de cette
revendication portait notamment sur la
cherté de la vie mais en vous organisant
de votre côté en défilant dans les rues
de fort de france
de votre côté pourquoi n'avoir pas fait
une jonction avec les gilet jaune 10 inc
alors monsieur partij doit rectifier
nous ne sommes jamais de démarquer du
gilet jaune parce que déjà les jeunes
ont exprimé très vite leur position en
disant comment il entendait s'organiser
et donc nous avons respecté ça mais nous
n'avons jamais condamné alors je
voudrais quand même revenir sur cette
question que vous avez posée où sont
passés les gilet jaune alors je dois
dire que ils ne sont pas visibles
peut-être dans les rues mais dans leur
tête les gilet jaune il y en a beaucoup
pendant cynique il y en a même des
milliers et des milliers
on croit tout simplement parce que ce
sont bien souvent et très souvent même
des salariés qui adhèrent aux
revendications et puis je voudrais dire
aussi une chose c'est que rappelez vous
il y a dix ans le 5 février
ça m'a fait une raison mais nous on
n'avait pas des gilet jaune ici mais on
avait des tee-shirts rouges et qui
pendant 38 jours ont tenu tête jusqu'à
obtenir un certain nombre de choses donc
il n'y a pas d'eau de 2
nous n'avons pas tourné le dos nous ne
reconnaissons que l'on peut ne pas avoir
une présence physique ils ne sont
peut-être pas visible mais dans leur
tête les revendications les exigences
quand même sur au co mais comment
expliquez vous en tant que syndicaliste
qui est habitué depuis des années des
années à organiser de manifestations de
rue à rendre visible une action
collective revendicative comment
expliquer cette relative discrétion vous
dites que nous sommes
il ya plusieurs milliers de salariés qui
sont gilet jaune dans leur tête mais
qu'il ne se manifeste pas pour autant
pas de grève
pas de défilé de rue ou très peu pas de
signes ostentatoires pas de pancarte de
slogan quel comment expliquez vous
écouter ceux qui ont pris l'initiative
de l'organiser de cette manière nous
respectons nous n'avons pas à leur
donner d'instruction nous n'avons pas le
faire de soudure puisqu'ils ont défini
très vite comment il entendait
s'organiser nous prenons acte simplement
nous avons simplement dit deux choses
que les gie des jeunes expriment des
revendications qu'ils peuvent et même
souvent rejoindre les revendications
syndicales par exemple il ya un point
sur lequel nous avons insisté c'est pour
cette raison que nous lorsque nous avons
appelé nos adhérents et en général des
salariés à s'organiser nous avons
privilégié un point c'est l'augmentation
des salaires et leur indexation sur
l'évolution des prix et nous avons
privilégié ce point là je note que les
jeunes expriment d'autres revendications
nous n'avons pas à porter de jugement là
dessus
merci de votre analyse ne se mange osez
vous voyez ça avec un peu de recul
doublement parce que vous êtes chef
d'entreprise qui avait beaucoup
participer aux états généraux de l'autre
main il y a quelques mois ça va faire
dix ans vous attendiez en martinique à
une mobilisation massive a à peu près
équivalente à celle de février 2009 à
l'occasion de ce mouvement des jeunes
et puis je vous réponds de jeu je sais
pas c'est pas quelques vous répondre on
a des difficultés parfois saisir un
petit peu les réactions la martinique
aurait beaucoup d'action parfois sont
spontanés inquiets
parce qu'il ya une marmite qui bout et
yaya nombre de problèmes qui sont qui
sont soulevées et un moment ça éclate
avec l'attaqué de différentes façons
comme se sait faire des minutes après sa
structure et donc mais au dépôt de
départ ça a été donc expiration un
moment on n'a pas vu les choses comme il
le fallait et ça ça a éclaté alors et
gilet jaune effectivement c'est une
nouvelle forme de manifestation puisque
c'est ni politique ni partie syndicale
pas de lit de donc pas de grève dans les
entreprises donner des mobilisations
essentiellement donc le week-end mais
avec un certain nombre de problématiques
sont soulevés équipe mais qui de façon
nous intéresse parce que ce sont des
pratiquants ce bien celle quand on parle
de réformes politiques quand on parle de
fiscalité qu'on parle de justice sociale
justice fiscale quand on parle de la vie
chère compte en parle et ça c'est un
problème
donc auquel on reviendra certainement
dans le trou discussions dans nos
échanges il est certain que nombre de
problèmes qui nous concernent toutes les
façons
le débat est ouvert le président l'a
bien dit toutes les questions peut-être
opposé donc au delà des cas tout 50 m
qui ont été dévoilées donc on peut poser
un certain nombre de questions alors
c'est vrai que la partie économique
peut-être les moins en avant pour le
moment mais manifestement nous savons
bien que tout pays se développe avec une
économie qui si ce n est pas rien tant
pis je me retourne vers vous rappelle
que vous êtes membre du conseil exécutif
de la collectivité territoriale de
martinique
la septième et vous êtes en particulier
chargé du développement économique donc
de la vie des entreprises 2 le direct ou
indirect à notre tissu productif et donc
vous suivez avec attention la situation
sociale
comment analysez vous ce mouvement d
gilet jaune qui n'a pas véritablement
percé en martinique où pour reprendre
l'image
monsieur jean-marie tout à l'heure il ya
des milliers de salarié qui songe et
légendes à leur tête même si ils
n'expriment pas leurs opinions leurs
sentiments publiquement des milliers de
personnes qui sont aussi les jeunes dans
leur tête mais aussi bon sur le
pare-brise parce qu'en fin de compte
enfin moi sur le parking devant chez moi
j'ai vu que les jours mis leur gilets
jaunes sur le tableau de bord disons ça
comme ça passe par de ce tableau de bord
donc pour dire qu'ils soutiennent le
soutiennent le mouvement
je pense je suis pas psychologue mais je
pense qu'il ya quand même eu un
traumatisme en 2009 quoi qu'on dise
alors c'est sûr que le mot syndicale
dira peut-être pas avec les mêmes mots
mai 2009 c'est effectivement plus près
de 38 jours de grève où s'étaient pas
une grève comme ce qui se passe parce
aujourd'hui à paris où tous les samedis
en bloc une économie c'était 38 jours où
tout a été bloqué les entreprises ont
été fermées totalement et les gens
descendent et tous les jours en ville et
quelque part je dis repartir sur un
mouvement de cette ampleur
je pense qu'aujourd'hui on y réfléchit à
deux fois
ceci étant vous couper la parole ce
n'est pas une grève qu'il y a
en france à paris à bordeaux de grande
vitesse samedi la vie économique
continue fin là mais lavier attendent et
quand vous entendez quand même le court
économique l'ia pour une même au niveau
des entreprises enfin qui ne qui sont
sur une période où ils font le maximum
de leur chiffre d'affaires il a
notamment pour le commerce il ya quand
même
cookie qui nous convient pas simplement
produit que la france mérite tenue de
vie voire de direction mais que rihanna
réunion à my only avoir loupé il y avait
justement depuis quelque part quelque
temps peut-être que on n'a pas envie je
pense je ne sais pas si y'a pas un
leader qui a émergé pour dire voici on
repart sur une un mouvement aussi aussi
dur même si les revendications peuvent
être tout à fait légitime
il ya eu quand même pas mal
d'entreprises confirmé après on n'a pas
fait ce bilan là on fait moi je n'ai pas
eu jeudi c'est aujourd'hui l'heure fed
un mouvement de cette ampleur et partir
pour dire qu'on va revendiquer pour pour
c'est quand même en fait sa demande à
prendre une certaine responsabilité là
où je rejoins madame baylet c'est vrai
qu'on peut se poser la question est ce
que les personnes se sentent ont besoin
peut-être d'un mouvement syndical pour
pouvoir se fédérer parce que quoi qu'on
dise en 2009 même si les syndicats
n'étaient pas au devant de la scène
quelques par le mouvement était très
vite quand même organisé par départ par
l'organisation c'est vrai que c'était
syndicale donc il y avait des personnes
je dirais qu'ils avaient l'habitude de
faire qui avait l'habitude d'organiser
de telles manifestations qui en
back-office faisait est à dire ce
travail d'organisation
donc c'était vraiment et peut-être qu'il
faut effectivement s'y connaître pour
pouvoir faire émerger un mouvement donc
là il n'y a pas de leaders qui ce qu'ils
se soient vraiment quelqu émergé sur les
réseaux sociaux n'y en a pas eu
par ailleurs s'il y en a eu mais enfin
n'a pas eu l'ampleur d'un leader pour
pouvoir regrouper le plus grand nombre
autour de lui et derrière les syndicats
ont respecté le fait que
le mouvement des jeunes voulaient pas
être récupéré par les syndicats donc on
se retrouve dans cette situation
mais bon ce n'est pas pour autant que je
dis des revendications on dise à sedan
les gens se sentait mal à l'aise ou en
désaccord avec le gouvernement on a le
même les mêmes revendications
ici quand les gens disent moi le 20 du
mois je suis à découvrir tous les mois
avec 2000 euros je ne je ne je ne vis
plus je suis seule avec deux enfants de
1000 euros je ne sais plus je pense que
beaucoup de martine caisse on retrouve
dans ses revendications ou aux biens le
smig
il ya déjà des personnes qui restent qui
sont diplômés qu'il reste dix ans 12 ans
smig cia il ya un vrai problème
bon maintenant est ce que quand on dit
on va augmenter les prix en vain d'aix
et les prix il faut que derrière ils
sont des simples citoyens et suivre ses
pas on ne décide pas d'augmenter des
prix comme ça ni des salaires jeudi
derrière il ya toute une économie et à
l'activité dernier à ce que l'activité
suit est ce que les entreprises suivent
quoi donc
et c'est tout ça à qui a les entreprises
étaient autour de la table on devine en
2009 puisque les fameux 200 euros qui
ont été donnés c'était 100 par l'état
sans par les entreprises donc jeudi a
enfin c'est le milieu on a vu le
résultat
résultat on a vu le nombre d'entreprises
qui konami qui ont été mises en
difficulté qui ont fermé le chômage qui
a augmenté a vu un certain nombre de
problèmes mais je pense que les
problèmes ne sont pas près d'être réglé
de façon à y voir un vrai projet fulham
arctique une vision oui il ya des
réformes qui sont nécessaires mais juste
jeu style et rené jamais revenue aux
niveaux de croissance d'avant 2009
jusqu'à présente à dire que dix ans plus
tard on est toujours à un niveau
d'activité de development en dessous de
2009 donc ça on a je dirais payer quand
même lourd tribut jeudi en ontario le
monde économique a quand même payé un
lourd tribut admiration
on n'a pas de sursaut qui aurait été
jeune trader soit allégée 2009
et je ne suis pas sûr que les gens sont
même s'en tirait mieux je me donnait la
parole monsieur jean-marie mais attendez
le questions soulevées leurs comptes
2009 disait après son camp l'hallali est
extrait la solution non plus quels que
soient les gouvernements à paris les
gouvernants à fort de france est
tolérable le mans cher gros des milliers
de voir la majorité des personnes soient
salariés avec des salaires faibles soit
alors qu'ils sont justement j'y suis
c'est pourquoi les salaires pourquoi
pourquoi pourquoi le coût des produits
qu'ils soient qu'ils soient produits
localement ou importés sont chers oui il
suffit bon on connaît on connaît on sait
pourquoi nous ramenez nous savons bien
que nous avons des chiens aux conditions
liées à l'éloignement et à l'insularité
donc la difficulté de faire des
économies d'échelle pour la production
locale et nous savons que les aides qui
sont apportées ne sont pas suffisantes
pour compenser les surcoûts aujourd'hui
et nous avons paré que me les produits
importés il y a déçu au coup qui sont
directs et indirects
et là aussi il y à un certain nombre de
problèmes alors je dis pas qu'il ya pas
une ou deux ni sur lequel bon mais c'est
pas faux pas ne pas faire sentir et
michel seni cela vous dire que c'est
tout le système qui ne fait pas la route
non on a aujourd'hui de vrais problèmes
lequel on veut pas on ne peut pas
vraiment pour différentes raisons
attaqué il ya un autre problème qui
concerne effectivement le sursalaire et
que sur lequel on n'avait toujours pas
parler on va juste prendre la parole
mais parce que parce que je pense que il
y a une seule phrase sur laquelle là
nous sommes tombés d'accord c'est qu'il
faut un véritable projet une véritable
vision pour la martinique
la deuxième chose je crois que on n'a
pas de boule de cristal et que personne
ne sait quel aurait été le la
trajectoire de la martinique
s'il n'y avait pas eu 2009 en
l'occurrence on est quand même arrivé
à une situation où les gens ont préféré
mettre en effet en danger et en péril
leur quotidien pour revendiquer des
choses qui étaient pour eux de l'est du
domaine de l'essentiel alors évidemment
dans l'essentiel l'essentiel d'une
entreprise n'est pas l'essentiel d'un
d'un salarié c'est vrai il ya alors
c'est marrant parce que alors quand
c'est les entreprises c'est vraiment
dramatique mais c'est contre ces les
gens ont fini par dire autre chose ou
qu'on appelle les personnes des dommages
collatéraux
évidemment que c'est dramatique mais
enfin je crois qu'à un moment il faut
remettre un peu d'humain d'humains au
centre de nos préoccupations politiques
se rendre compte que le schéma que l'on
veut construire ne peut pas être
toujours le même vous dit que il ya un
problème avec les prix moi je veux bien
mais enfin tous les chefs d'entreprise
ici connaissent l'insularité et font des
programmations lorsqu'ils montent une
entreprise ou lorsqu'ils veulent la
pérenniser sur les coûts que ça
représente pour autant on se rend compte
quand même
pour autant on se rend compte quand même
un que moi je vais pas payer vous le
savez très bien je vais pas payer le
transport maritime le même prix que vous
parce que vous vous faites des économies
d'échelle en important beaucoup parce
que vous avez probablement des tarifs
particuliers parce que vous êtes un
client fidèle de certaines entreprises
et qu' il y a beaucoup de gens notamment
dans l'agroalimentaire qui sont dans la
même situation
et quand on voit des x 4 x 5 sur des
marchandises alors qu'on sait que
globalement sur certaines d'entre elles
transport compris taxe octroi de mer
compris on est à un différentiel de 13 %
avec la métropole
on se dit que quand on arrive à du 100 %
de différence il y a quand même là
quelque chose de caché qui dérange et
les gens s'en rendent de plus en plus
compte
et il s'en rendre compte surtout et non
seulement il se rendre compte de ça
parce que moi je faisais hier parce que
je capte mal chez moi j'ai décidé de
regarder le prix de comparer les prix
une fois encore deux des
télécommunications
non seulement ici on a un opérateur par
exemple qui s'appelle orange qui s'est
gavé pendant 40 ans sur les outre mer d
outre-mer de locaux comme les outre-mer
habitants
notamment l'hexagone et qui arrive à
nous vendre encore des abonnements
téléphoniques notamment mobiles mais
aussi des solutions et on va peut-être
parler aussi de ce qu'ils posent
difficulté comme la rupture numérique et
d'autres sujets on arrive aujourd'hui à
un opérateur qui ne respectent même pas
les outre mer qui nous vaut un produit
plus cher
on pourrait le comprendre on va nous
parler d'infrastructures de difficultés
mais non seulement elles vont on
l'achète plus cher mais il est de moins
bonne qualité il ya moins de services il
y a moins de services il est de moins
bonne qualité dans sa composition est
dans ce qu'on vend alors au bout d'un
moment ça ça fait longtemps que les gens
le remarquent encore les prix ont baissé
parce qu'on a des opérateurs qui sont
arrivés mais en 2009 les gens paient un
abonnement téléphonique à plus de 100
euros à plus de 100 euros et un
abonnement internet quasiment même prix
nous sommes dans face à la première vous
l'aurez compris c'est martinique la
première c'est notre émission politique
hebdomadaire un gadget jean-marie vous
avez bondi à plusieurs reprises lors de
l' échange tout à l'heure la cherté de
la vie le pouvoir d'achat reste une
question centrale depuis des décennies
en art unique et dans les premières en
général il faut une vision d'avenir il
faut un projet de développement dit
pierre marie joseph chef d'entreprise à
l'instant que pouvez-vous répondre à 101
une viande à venir un projet
développement suffit-il à juguler cette
hausse vertigineuse des prix et cette
vie qui est trop cher pour la majorité
de nos concitoyens normes afin de
devenir moi j'entends 2009 les 40 % je
pense que certains se découvrent de plus
en plus puisque on vise une catégorie de
salariés et 40 % dois je dire monsieur
marie-josèphe que les 40% des salariés
atterrissent ni plus ni moins ce que
dans les caisses des entreprises donc
les bénéficiaires c'est encore eux quant
à 2009 faudra peut-être qu'à un moment
vous arrêtiez de me rendre 2009
responsable de tous les maux
j'entends madame taureau puis dire que
le coût n'a pas été fait de la grève de
2009 tout comme j'attends de savoir
combien ça a coûté le blocage de
l'aéroport en 1992 ou un cône avion ne
pouvait atterrir et parce qu'une
catégorie s'est gavé et monte et est
revenu à sabler le champagne dans le
rôle de l'aéroport d'accord et il faut
parler du blocage des aéroports des
pointes à plus de fort de france
les planteurs de bohaly 30 heures de
batterie et empires de la lune
organisation commune de marché d'amazon
paul donc 2009
alors il y avait des entreprises qui
était certes en difficulté mais bien
avant donc 2000 ne les a tuées 2009 n'a
pas tué et j'en connais beaucoup qui on
en tirer profit et qui sont encore là
moi ce n'est pas vous parler d'un coût
économique
moi je parle aussi d'un coût social
d'accord parce qu'il s'agit pas
seulement de se poser du côté de des
chefs d'entreprise je fais remarquer une
chose c'est que nous sommes dans une
économie organisé d'une certaine manière
et que des salariés ne dirige pas je
voudrais le faire remarquer mais où les
salariés de michelin juste au pays ou
d'un que ben justement il ne dirige pas
donc ils subissent ils subissent je fais
remarquer une chose c'est que sur ce
plateau il y a deux fonctionnaires
puisque encore que le terme
fonctionnaires c'est devenu une
expression presque mépris et que les
salaires de ces deux fonctionnaires sont
bloquées depuis 2010 il n'empêche que on
vit alors on a on entend beaucoup de
choses
moi je vais dire une chose il faudra
qu'on revienne à l'essentiel les prix
sont élevés la cherté de la vie
oui la situation persiste elles
perdurent et s'aggravent elle s'aggrave
et le chômage c'est un scandale c'est un
fléau et il y à beaucoup d'autres choses
maintenant moi ce que je note et je vais
tout simplement pas rester sans que le
simple cadre de la martinique
parce que la martinique c'est une tête
d'épinglé mais qui évolue dans un
contexte mondial je note que en 2017
les profits des entreprises ont été de
près de 5 milliards d'euros
à tel point que le service
mesnil il y à il y a un effet puisque un
terme qu'on emploie souvent c'est le
terme de ruissellement donc
nécessairement certains d'en profiter
mais on fera pas les salariés et ça je
le maintiens 100 milliards d'euros en
2010 est ce qui a permis de distribuer
en 2010 8 58 milliards de dividendes
versés aux actionnaires et en non je me
sens bien je ne sais plus si les échos
la tribune qui disait ne jamais vu
depuis 2007
quand une situation s'aggrave au
certains et la très grande majorité
d'autres se gavent oui d'autres se
gavent mine alors monsieur s'est mis
nous y compris l'essence aider les
entreprises c'est quelque chose
intéressante ce qu'on vous dit madame
topping que c'est une minorité mais
c'est une minorité s'organise et
précipite eu la très grande majorité des
zones la lozère le thé dans le désarroi
et c'est ça le problème
et c'est ça mais je ne défends pas les
entreprises non pardon je défendrai pas
les grandes entreprises
madame vous même abandonné à une
catégorie chef d'entreprise vous avez
été plaisant de calais le sida je mange
je savais que je suis je suis salarié et
je suis sûr liger je ne sais pas je suis
un salarié et je suis solidaire de tous
les salariés s'ils veulent nous en
détacher
oui car ils ont fait plus de 4 à
ouattara zana allée nomi un seul jeu là
un salarié je suis sur ce plateau je
prends la coche défend la cause des
salariés et j'en suis solidaire mais
vous comprenez monsieur jean-marie qu'il
ya plusieurs catégories d'entreprises
commandes en main
notre gauche par exemple si les salariés
mais on est en train de s'éloigner du
sujet je vois et j'entends commerciaux à
la fois s'il vous plaît monsieur
marie josèphe qui parle de cadres abc
manifestement monsieur marc joseph fait
une fixation sur une catégorie de
salariés pourquoi mais permettez que
j'aille jusqu'au moins bien il y à des
salariés nous disent que quand même il y
à des salariés qui sont soit dans la
fonction publique soit dans le privé ce
sont des salariés
la société est organisée comme elle et
moi je note aujourd'hui que dans la rue
et je te ça va peut-être vous sûrement y
compris en faisant la question du gilet
jaune
il y à un certain nombre de personnes
qui sont des travailleurs indépendants
des chefs d'entreprise ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire crois ça veut dire que
cette société paupérise poli un grand
nombre de personnes et que de plus en
plus de personnes sont précipités vers
une catégorie ce qui me permet de dire
ce qui me permet de dire que dans un
avenir plus ou moins proche
on aura à nouveau un 2009 en martinique
et je l'espère et j'attende et j'appelle
les travailleurs dans les entreprises à
se mêler et à s'engouffrer dans le
chemin des filets jaunes n'ont pas boudé
samedi seulement mais de manière durable
pour que effectivement ils puissent
défendre leurs intérêts et en
particulier la question des salaires des
pensions des minima sociaux des
allocations et que encore une fois que
ce soit indexée sur les prix car marie
josèphe
évidemment vous avez une vision claire
revenir si on pouvait élargir élever le
débat
la notion de vision du développement
oui mais également ce serait intéressant
absolument mais ce que dit monsieur
jean-marie ce parce que on se retrouve
si on prend le temps de s'écouter on va
se retrouver si beaucoup de choses parce
que quand il parle effectivement de deux
certain nombre d'entrepreneurs
indépendants ou des entrepreneurs de
petites entreprises donc des tp on nous
savons que 95 % du tissu donc
martiniquais est composé donc de tp donc
nous sommes battus et comme je disais
sans vexer qui que ce soit les revenus
de certains nombre d'équipés de de tps
exception que je ne fais pas de fixation
c'est monsieur mari qui était après est
largement inférieur parfois aux revenus
de certaines catégories professionnelles
c'est une évidence et une réalité avec
de petits bergers
alors alors pour revenir au et pour
recentrer le débat sur deux
problématiques essentielles au delà des
problèmes de santé d'éducation
d'autres beaux trop problème de réformes
d'organisation politique et autres dont
on peut parler il ya aussi sur la
martinique deux problèmes essentiels et
le et copains et introduit par l'autre
c'est le chômage
effectivement la vie chère le pouvoir
d'achat à lomé s'arrête on parle quand
on parle de pouvoir d'achat
et quand on parle de ça les a incités à
deux personnes qui n'ont pas et je le
reconnais que vous avez vous verser un
salaire à quelqu'un et vous vous
demandez comment il fera pour pouvoir
payer tout ce qu'elle a appelé vu le co
est vu le transport qui n'est pas tout à
fait un gain organisé comme il le
faudrait donc des coûts supplémentaires
où il ya deux voitures dans une maison
là où métropole ou dans les pays s'est
organisée hier à zéro voiture ou une
voiture qu'ils aient le week-end quand
on la sait il conte à 16 cents 600 euros
pour le transport
là bas nous n'a que 50 50 euros en cas
d'orage en fait si vous voulez ya
certain nombre de problèmes qui rentre
et qui viennent et c'est finalement
presque l'employeur qui devient l'âme au
tissu social et qui est sous qui on doit
compter de quelle façon la quelle
manière vous personnellement dans vos
entreprises
qu'est ce qu'on fait mais nous avons
nous avons fait que nous avancions
salaires nous faisons des acomptes
raison des des prêts sans intérêts aux
nous accompagnons en permanence parce
que nous avons nous sommes conscients
que nous avons effectivement un problème
sur le pouvoir d'achat pour ne pas
augmenter les salaires n'augmentent le
salaire mais j'augmente les prix aussi
c'est parce que c'est ça le problème je
veux augmenter les salaires
augmentez mépris je vais sortir de la
compétition parce que nous sommes c'est
une compétition pas seulement local
patiente comme comme si athènes nous
sommes c'est une coutume chez une
compétition donc nationale et
internationale tu veux dire que moi je
vais augmenter mépris mais bon je
répercute et surtout en chine
c'est quoi les gens n'achètent pas ne
sont pas leurs noms mais de pouvoir
d'achat et sur une dernière phrase c'est
à dire que augmenter le pouvoir d'achat
ce n'est pas obligatoirement augmenter
les salaires ça veut dire aussi c'est
peut-être diminuer diminué de
réfrigérant les prix pour augmenter le
pouvoir d'achat sont maintenant le
pouvoir d'achat de tous ceux qui
auraient parce que vous êtes absolument
pas contre ce que vous croyez puisque
mes parents l'été je ne suis absolument
pas contre
parce que de toutes les façons
aujourd'hui dans le modèle économique
qui tout le monde ya atteint ses limites
donc si on enlève brutalement donc
cesser ces sommes et c'est certain qu'on
aura un grave problème nokia une re
travail de fond quitte à faire il faut
toujours préserver le pouvoir d'achat je
le répèterai toute ma vie préserver le
pouvoir d'achat de toutes chacun celui
qu'il a actuellement
par contre nous pouvons augmenter le
pouvoir d'achat d'autres en prenant
d'autres mesures pour pouvoir améliorer
la consommation éthique et l'a étiré
l'économie du pays alors pour politiser
un peu plus nos démarches ou cannes pour
lui donner une lecture plus politique
une question me vient à l'esprit en
lisant en regardant consultant les
archives des journaux et des
organisations syndicales des tracks de
ces dernières années dès 1949 vous voyez
ça ça remonte donc depuis 1949 ça fait
soixante dix ans que chaque année on a
des revendications des analyses ion
lavier trop cher le pouvoir d'achat des
masses laborieuses était trop bas les
salaires sont trop bas les produits
importés sont trop onéreux il c'est
scandaleux il faut faire quelque chose
depuis 70 ans
on dit ça quels que soient les
gouvernements on est passé de la 4e à la
5e un peu les craintes demeurent en
sixième
la gauche a dirigé la droite a dirigé et
a toujours alors vos quêtes politique
madame ton pays comment
tous nos grands parents avaient le même
problème que qu'aujourd'hui cela montre
déjà que toutes les revendications qui
ont été organisées et que toutes les
réponses qui ont été apportées ne
convenait pas puisque le problème est le
même vous dit il on le retrouve dans
différentes façons dont un moment donné
il faudrait peut-être poser les vraies
questions j'ai alors qu'elle convoque
alors je repense je reprends tout à
l'heure l'exemple cas dembélé sous les
opérateurs numériques pas numéro
téléphonique et/ou mais c'est vrai qu'il
ya eu une exagération et c'est là que
quand on demande une certaine égalité
par complexe
il aurait fallu qu'il y ait vu hier
jeudi est une vraie vrai combat là
dessus non parce que je dis là le
problème qui a c'est qu'aujourd'hui on
se pose la question est ce qu'on va
faire le grand débat est-ce qu'on va y
participer
oui il faut y participer je ne peux pas
penser qu'au moment donné on nous donne
la parole et qu'on ne la prennent pas
puisque si on n'y participent pas selon
dire que nous n'avons nous pas les
pointes pour des missions qui sont
candidats au quoi vous faire masser ou
de votre groupe politique m'a payé
jusqu'à ce que moi je dis aux reprises
et je vais m'organiser
dans mon groupe au niveau de chercheurs
je veux organiser des des moments de
parole parce que là je pense qu'il faut
que les gens s'expriment et disent
aujourd'hui avec les réseaux sociaux
nous sommes sur un autre type de
communication où on arrive véritablement
à je dirais à porter sa parole est à
faire et âme à faire am a engendré enfin
avoir des personnes qui soutiennent
votre votre parole et et vos
revendications
je pense qu'il faut regarder les
problèmes vraiment de façon je dirais
pas seulement sur le problème on est en
restera toujours soin problèmes
alimentaires le problème alimentaire
c'est une c'est c'était une autre c'est
alimentaire c'est là bas mais c'est
l'essentiel
oui mais c'est les oriels je suis
d'accord que c'est l'essentiel c'est à
dire que les gens tous les matins dans
l'eau au quotidien
moi j'ai rencontré comme je le dis parce
que tout le monde la réalité des gens il
faut commencer politiquement vraie
demande à ce qu'on donne à 1
et moi je parle en effet du projet et
moi je me dis qu'on ne peut pas même en
tant que politique martiniquais
continuer à faire de la population des
ultras consommateurs on consomme tout
voilà donc on consomme ce qu'il y à
manger on ne donne pas de solution aux
gens on consomme de la pollution donne
pas de solution on consomme des voitures
en donne pas de solution on et vous
parlez de 70 ans
nous n'avons toujours pas en effet un
réseau de transports alors que nous
savons a fait 30 ans que c'est dans tous
les débats dans toutes les assemblées
dont nous n'avons pas encore aujourd'hui
la solution définitive de la mise en
place d'un réseau cohérent sur la
martinique d'un réseau de transport faut
le dire faut le dire faut dire que si
les gens sont obligés d'acheter chacun
leur voiture
ben c'est à cause de ça mais au-delà de
ça ça veut dire que il ya aussi un
déficit dans le projet et pas seulement
dans le projet dans la façon de faire
sens de faire commun est de faire
société ensemble nous sommes incapables
en martinique d'avoir des projets
pérennes qui nous permette d'aller
alors certains n'aiment pas ça mais moi
j'aime bien le dire quand même vers une
vision d'excellence notre territoire
nous avons cette obligation probablement
parce que nous sommes éloignés
probablement parce que nous sommes
petits mais d'aller vers l'excellence
parce que le moyen nous ne pouvons pas
d'autres le font à côté de chez nous
nous devons être excellent sur les
domaines dans lesquels nous avons des
marges de manoeuvre par exemple les les
services à distance et notamment le
numérique nous c'est des choses qui
coûtent pas obligatoirement et qui
pourtant peuvent être intéressants
arriver aujourd'hui par exemple à faire
du territoire martinique une sorte de
territoire d'expérimentation notamment
en matière de bio et sur le
développement justement de culture qui
vont à contrario de l'utilisation des
pesticides encore il n'ya pas longtemps
à l'europe une
proposition a été votée par un grand
nombre de députés européens français
pourquoi pour dire nous devons très
rapidement sortir par exemple des
pesticides tels que le glyphosate est
chez nous on aurait pu se poser la
question parce que nous sommes
troisièmes par exemple encore une fois
troisième consommateur de glyphosate en
france donc pourquoi ne pas aller sur
des filières d'excellence et de
recherche sur la recherche
nous avons de quoi faire sur la
recherche océanique nous avons de quoi
faire nous avons en effet un territoire
marin donc il ya peut-être des choses et
des chants sur lesquels nous pouvons
développer et des chants sur lesquels
nous ne pouvons pas faire nous ne
pouvons pas avoir un tissu industriel à
la mesure de ce que l'on pourrait
trouver sur un territoire hexagonal
s'est faut pas faire rêver faut pas
faire rêver sur des domaines sur
lesquels et on va pas pouvoir faire
et de fait on va toujours avoir des
différentiels de prix sur des
productions sur lesquels nous n'avons
aucun intérêt ou gâteaux armand un
produit réellement sauf à aller vers la
qualité est là je parle à un artisan
on va vers la qualité on a un service
après-vente on a quelque chose doit on
s'ajuste hi fi d'un prix mais c'est vrai
que nous sommes devenus des hypers
consommateurs et que les gens ne s'y
retrouvent plus donc c'est le modèle
qu'il faut changer et ce sont les
politiques publiques qui doivent
s'inscrire dans la continuité parce que
les gie des jeunes c'est aussi ça c'est
une fronde démocratique parce que les
gens ne croient plus en ce que les élus
disent les élus disent quelque chose un
jour
le lendemain lorsque l'on change de
gouvernance c'est autre chose et on qu'à
celui ce qui a été fait par le précédent
donc quand je disais j'introduis they
par le fait de dire nous devons faire
sens commun et à un moment nous devons
arriver à faire société
donc à se dire que nous créons pour du
moyen et du long terme peut-être que
nous arriverons à définir des solutions
qui seront reçus pérenne qui sont anti
j'ai quand même interrompu m j'ai
terminé sur le fait de dire ce qu'on
disait non c'est vrai qu'à le problème
de l'agroalimentaire et de la partie
alimentaire est à dire des produits
alimentaires mais l'enjeu voulais dire
c'est que sur la production alimentaire
nous pouvons effectivement avoir
une action qui sera acquis qui fait que
je dis on peut organiser notre un jour
notre alimentation on peut sur ses prix
par rapport à la concurrence
on voit bien qu'on arrive quand même à
jouer sous les prix or sur les
opérateurs sur les coûts du numérique
sur le coup par exemple de l'industrie
sous le coup des voitures là si nous
n'avons pas une action qui qui qui est
vraiment une action forte qu'on puisse
contrainte ces personnes qui font du but
de la marche je dirais de façon je
dirais scandaleuse vous y êtes la manche
de façon scandaleuse alors que sur
l'alimentaire on y lit a toujours quand
même 7 7 7 concurrence et en plus on
pourrait réorganiser notre notre
production nous pour faire en sorte
qu'il y ait qu il n'y ait pas cette ces
prix qui montent comme on voit pas dans
les autres secteurs
l'émission parce que vite face à la
première en martinique la première notre
émission politique monsieur marc joseph
deux mots de 10 projets que vous appelez
de vos voeux en à 100 on a entendu en
filigrane quelques quelques lots mais
d'après vous mettons que demain vous
prisé de la martinique
rien ne vaut un peu quelles priorités
quelle réflexion quelle piste allez-vous
mettre en avant vous souhaiteriez vous
mettre en avant pour sortir du marasme
de leurs oignons que nous connaissons
comme je le disais peu plus du temps de
nos grands parents
la réflexion pour tous sur le sirop
premiers éléments il faut me retiens
c'est le chômage
on est au chômage il est inacceptable à
partir de ce moment là il faut donc
véritablement avec tous les travaux qui
ont été faits et tout ce qui a été fait
en termes de
statistiques tant par le pôle emploi tu
pars pas par l'insee on a cet énorme
d'éléments des métiers en tension
alors moi je j'entends beaucoup de joie
d'auto de la tablée mais moi tout ce qui
concerne les métiers donc deux de ses
sorties fichiers le technologies
nouvelles stella c'est très bien il faut
y aller mais il faut quand même que nous
pensions que 60 % de notre population
active à une formation qui est reprise
aujourd'hui à tous le cep et le
baccalauréat jaune je n'entends pas
parler par exemple des services à la
personne mais quelle quelques mois nous
avons dans mes moments françois non mais
en france aussi nous avons déjà une
population donc oui mais on en a besoin
aussi elle peut travailler quand on
parle de 10 pour la population tombe le
pas mais aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'on
fait véritablement pour construire alors
là il ya les travaux qui sont en train
d'être fait pour on parle on parle
souvent de de l'epal à domicile pas de
beaucoup choses actuellement qui sont
très intéressants qui vont vraiment dans
le sens de l'avenir mais il ya toute une
formation donc et l'accompagnement des
entreprises qui oeuvrent de ce domaine
pour pouvoir donc maîtriser un petit peu
les coûts la charge ne reste à payer
pour pour les familles etc
il ya une d'emploi de masse dont tous
les services à la personne aux
entreprises qui peut nous permettre de
diminuer
donc ce chômage endémique qui fait
qu'ils etc etc etc etc est insupportable
pour notre population
tone éléments qui est important et quand
on va reparler de l'industrie non
l'industrie a à sa place mais bien sûr
aucun industriel n'ira construire des
voitures ici conçue et des télés ou
autres ici bien entendu mais il ya un
certain nombre de secteurs qui ont leur
place à partir du moment où ils sont
structurés organisés suivant cette
énorme de niche
ils ont leur place puisque nous avons vu
des secteurs qui aujourd'hui bien
sculptures et bien l'organiser comme la
banane le rhum ou le sucre a donc à la
réunion où il montrait une partie de
l'agoa l'iman terre des transports ainsi
ceux qui ont su s'organiser se
structurer qui ont soulevé aussi un
certain nombre d' aide qui compense
véritablement de façon correcte le sioux
coup parce qu'il ya des fois il ya un
besoin effectivement de sortir des
résultats qui est des investissements
qui sont importants iliad et de la
recherche du développement et ses terres
et c'est donc ces entreprises là s'en
sort donc ça montre bien que il faut que
nous continuions à 12 à développer tous
nos secteurs donc de façon réfléchie
cette seconde
hier soir les jeunes de l'hôtellerie non
mais je suis pas sûr que la vieillesse
ou et niche dans bien aimé jouer demain
encore faut-il mais encore faut-il
écouter aujourd'hui lorsque vous allez
dans une classe de 3e avec les élèves et
que vous demandez une classe de 3e de 35
élèves combien compte dans dix ans être
en martinique il n'y en a pas un qui
vous dit oui bon pour moi et ceux qui
restent ils se sentent quoi ils se sont
enfermés parce qu'ils se sont déclarés
dans la police et 100 % nous mais c'est
pour ça que je vous dis mais c'est mais
aujourd'hui la trajectoire du fameux
celle d'une activité là monsieur vous
avez parlé juste rapidement juste parce
qu'il faut quand même faire après des
constats et je pense que ce serait
presque débuté par sa part faire un
diagnostic
le diagnostic de la martinique c'est
quoi le diagnostic de la martinique
c'est près de 40 % le taux de pauvreté
je vais vous dire pourquoi on dit 23
pourquoi parce que eh bien là par
exemple un combat politique pour qu'on
dise la vérité pour qu'on se regarde en
face la martinique le taux de pauvreté
le seuil de pauvreté en martinique est
fixé par l'insee à 680 et quelques euros
accor 680 euros faire que si vous en
avez 700 vous n'êtes pas pauvre pour les
statistiques de l'insee en martinique
d'accord bon sauf qu'il à 1020 euros en
france d'accord donc à partir c'est
seulement en deçà de 1020 euros que vous
êtes considérés comme pauvres en france
en martinique sens de sa de 680 euros
donc comme vous avez des politiques
publiques qui sont pensés par l'état et
que vous allez vers un territoire par
exemple qui est la réunion et qui a été
aligné sur le taux le seuil de pauvreté
de la france hexagonale
alors que l'on aurait probablement dû
nous avoir un seuil de pauvreté plus
haut puisque on sait que les prix sont
plus chers
quand vous avez des politiques publiques
qui sont pensés est ce que c'est mais
c'est de les terroriser en avait qu'un
seul des deux fêtes de labrihe laquelle
ils sont pensés avec un centre de
pauvreté remarque tout à fait non non
je lui impose de l'été mais c'était
finalement mis hors de cause
je voulais bien ses balles à cette date
ou maintenant s'il en effet même vous
payez un cabinet en ce moment non alors
il faut demander à votre collègue
monsieur francis carroll qui va vous
donner des éléments
et oui mais un cabinet pour faire cela
l'accusé en l'occurrence et 40 cents
soit très bas non loin de la théorie
sont des chinois voyez ça n'a pas tout à
fait le même sens et même c'est à dire
de façon dieu merci merci messieurs
dames nc l'émission puisque nous sommes
à la conclusion de notre dame à gabriel
germain amis qui vous parlais tout à
l'heure du projet et vous n'êtes pas
fondamentalement opposés à ce que
monsieur marie joseph et il est tout à
l'heure quant aux projets à inventer
pour sentir la martinique du marasme et
il a fallu faire à toucher les rivages
de l'excellence alors je vais dire
quelque chose en étant persuadé certain
que je n'apprends rien à personne
la martinique c'est 1000 km² la
martinique fait partie d'un pays plus
vaste qui s'appelle la france la france
évolue dans un contexte international
on évolue dans le contexte mondial
international
lorsqu'on appelle une économie de marché
je ne peux pas concevoir moi ici la
martinique qui s'en sortirait ici on
développerait des projets spécifiques
particulier qui permettrait de mettre la
menthe unique à l'abri de d'un certain
nombre d'aléas rude
je voudrais rappeler ici que nous
évoluons dans un système économique dans
une économie libérale dans une économie
de marché dans une économie de type
capitaliste
j'entends monsieur marie-josèphe dire
des choses un chômage inacceptable mais
monsieur matzneff par les ans donc à
ceux dont vous vous retrouvez dans le
même temps les chefs d'entreprise peu
importe leur taille puisque vous savez
très bien monsieur marie-josèphe que
lorsqu'on crée une entreprise on crée
pas une entreprise pour lutter contre le
chômage
on ne crée pas une entreprise pour
lutter contre la famine ont créé une
entreprise pour faire du fric
déjà ce monsieur c'est secret au boulot
je vais marie-josèphe jusque là je suis
sérieux madame tant pis je suis sérieux
non j'étais nombre de salles en salles
et vous avez un chef d'entreprise dit là
je viens c'est pour faire du profit de
monsieur marc joseph
oui les parties 0 monsieur marc joseph
oui vous êtes partis de zéro et c'était
tellement mal pour vous que vous êtes là
bon je le dis comme ça bien drôle je
vous êtes toujours là et oui oui bon je
disais donc qu'une chose c'est que quand
on crée une entreprise on ne crée pas
une entreprise pour lutter contre la
famine pour lutter contre le chômage on
crée une entreprise on veut qu'elle soit
rentable
on veut créer une entreprise ou faire du
profit des bénéfices sinon vous dira que
ce n'est pas rentable et ça devrait nous
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
pour terminer les médias les images
changent alors il ya une chose que
j'entends et c'est vous qui l'avez vous
avez donné cette date de 1949 très bien
mais on pourrait remonter aussi 1939
on sait ce qui s'est passé et on sait
pourquoi on est arrivé là 1929 1919
et puis on pourrait redescendre encore
68 69
on a eu 2009 et ainsi de suite on a eu
des 159 et si oui mais qu'est ce que
vous voulez comprendre plusieurs bornes
en off comme ça et puis on a eu 2009
je vais je vais dire une chose toute
simple on est dans un environnement
international
on est dans un contexte et ce ne sont
pas des solutions bêtise je vais dire
comme ça un petit peu de ci un petit peu
de c'est un petit peu de ses parts large
qui va régler le problème
alors monsieur partie lorsque vous nous
avez invité vous nous avez donné un
certain nombre de points qu'eux mais
nous n'allons pas tous les abonnements
possibles évidemment pas facile parce
que moi je voudrais quand même dire une
chose et je terminais là dessus parce
que je voudrais pas que ceux qui nous
écoutent et notamment les salariés
pas monsieur gauche parce que là il est
avec ses amis et qui j'espère qu'ils
vont le garder suffisamment au chaud
pendant longtemps et il en a encore un
petit peu trop en liberté comme ça mais
vous me croirez dg de nissan rhone je
parle de ce pays géant parce que je sais
et vous le savez que ça qu'il a fait
avec les politiques mènent en place mise
en place et combien de salariés se
retrouvent à la rue dans la misère ceci
est inclus contre il ya un grand débat
qui mit en place grand débat national je
voudrais dire la chose suivante à ceux
qui ont encore des illusions sur ce
débat je voudrais citer juste dans la
lettre de monsieur macron deux phrases
et ce sont les seules phrases qui sont
importantes là dedans je n'ai pas oublié
que j'ai été élu sur un projet sur deux
grandes orientations auxquelles je
demeure fidèle et il poursuit un peu
plus loin
nous ne reviendrons pas sur les mesures
que nous avons prises
autrement dit tout ça c'est du bavardage
c'est les paroles inutiles
on est en train de mener les géants
bateau et d'autres vous essayez de
donner aux gens l'impression l'illusion
que quelque chose va changer
rien ne changera simplement il faut
adapter pour mieux faire passer une
pilule amère et c'est pour cette raison
que le monde du travail doit s'organiser
pour ne pas subir les effets de cette
politique inique de prenez la
responsabilité que nous prenons le
destiner aux mais alors les travailleurs
seront le fer quand ils ont bien pris
conscience d'un certain nombre de choses
et croyez moi ils vont savoir réagir et
certains ça ne sera pas comme 2009
croyez moi merci et gabriel jean marie
sur lequel générale de la cgtm qui avait
conclu l'émission pierre marie joseph
chef d'entreprise président d'honneur de
la hem pays des industriels béatrice bel
et du parti socialiste qui a appris à
quelques mois la direction de la
fédération de lentilles nique et
marinette tant pis du conseil exécutif
de la ctc change et du développement
économique du groupe bat pays en chance
qui avait participé à ce débat nous le
reprendrons je vous donne quatre
semaines
dans une eau mais c'est vrai mais si
vous voulez trois heures d'émission je
viens vous référer à ma direction
en fait plus prosaïquement nous pouvons
nous retrouver dans quelques semaines
avec les mêmes invités si vous le
souhaitez pour faire une sorte de bilan
d'étape de ce débat qui va prendre tout
de même on a retenu contre voilà après
ou même pendant pendant dans quelques
semaines madame monsieur mes seins si
c'était donc face à la première réalisée
aujourd'hui par cedrick banks et à la
semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle
édition de notre émission à bientôt
face à la première
[Musique]